[Music]
thanks for joining us America we're glad
you're here our open phones a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
matters in Fort Lauderdale hey Matt how
are you thank you for taking my call
enjoy beating you this weekend thank you
sir how can I help ok well I got a
question about my son he is I've got two
boys one's doing great ones doing
terrible
he's turning eighteen on Friday just
graduated high school this week he was
living with beige for about four months
I had relocated to a different home so
that he I would have room for him and he
could go to college down here he is in
rebellion multiple arrests drug use if I
repeated what he called my wife just
before he left and went to his mother's
I get you thrown off the air
he's now in living with his mom and
incredibly angry at me calling my wife
all kinds of words and I'm trying to
struggle with the balance between do I
help him with at this stage in this
state of mind with tech school no
absolutely not absolutely not okay and
how do i I'm struggling with feeling
selfish about not doing that dude
anybody calls my wife that doesn't get
any of my money ever okay if it's that
simple I appreciate ya I mean I had a
fifteen-year-old daughter one time I
won't say which one was saying stuff to
her mom as I walked in and I said you
may be willing to talk to your mother
that way but no one talks to my wife
that way and lives okay you know I mean
really that that's this little guy I
mean he's crossed the line he's crossed
the line so listen you want my help then
you play by my rules and my rules are
good for not not selfish it's not
selfish you're protecting your wife okay
and you know and for that matter if you
endorse this behavior by giving him
money that doesn't turn him into a
thirty year old man he's a little twit
now he turns into a thirty year old man
but right now he's a twit you and I have
to agree to that you know yeah he could
turn around I mean I was a twit when I
was eight
I kind of recognize he's got a that he's
not on a path that's gonna lead him
anywhere positive okay no I appreciate
and I guess the corollary that aren't be
the question then is listen he does have
a come-to-jesus moment you know I pray
for that everyday a man and that does
happen you know I put him through
private school to finish his high school
because he couldn't be survived in a
regular environment there's a battle a
battle every time something something
gets hard it's a major ordeal to get him
to continue right I don't want to get on
the hook for tuition or anything like
that so my thought process is anybody go
out pacing the first semester I don't
even want to hear how you do it I will
reimburse you up to X number of dollars
upon completion of the semester with a
great point of a 3.0 or better yeah
let's stop a second the thing we want to
do here once we have a come-to-jesus
meeting a repentance okay right until
there's a repentance a turning from this
behavior you cannot endorse it infant
financially because it's not good for
him if you're giving a drunk a drink
you're rewarding his misbehavior and no
one else in this world is going to
reward this kind of behavior you know he
won't be able to call a job he won't be
able to hold a marriage he won't be able
to hold anything with the way he's
acting
and so what's good for him is for life
to get hard and push him to his knees
now once he's there then you give you
say all right the way you ask yourself
the question is how can I help him in a
way that causes him to be the 30 year
old man that he needs to be okay what is
the what are the steps and if the step
is the one you suggested there then
that's an okay that's the way if that's
the way you answer the question okay I
think the best way to help you is let
you gut it out for one semester and then
I'll get involved or you know the best
way to help you is I'll match you you
know whatever you come up with out put
some with it but the instant that you
stop behaving in a way that represents
good moral character and politeness to
fam
as part of that then you're you're gonna
get no more money that instant and I'm
not gonna beg you to go to school or do
your studies you're freaking 18 years
old so if you go and you study and you
get good grades and you live a life
consistent with a moral character and
you know politeness and manners and
decisions that are gonna lead you to
being a good 30 year old man I'm gonna
support that track financially because
it's good for him see there's nothing
selfish in this discussion at all it's
all in how are we gonna help him but you
know if he's doing heroin and we give
him money because we feel selfish what
have we got we're gonna kill our kid
they're gonna die of a heroin overdose
right and all that is is one kind of
misbehavior this is another kind of
misbehavior you cannot finance this
behavior it's because it's not good for
him true okay he's not gonna turn out
unless he changes exactly he's gonna end
up in a ditch all of his life due to his
selfish immature rebellious ways and hey
a lot of us went through stuff like that
a lot of us were stupid man I mean
mm-hmm
I was I was a half a notch better you
know and so I'm not I'm not I'm just
saying that we you know the only way you
can reward this kid with anything even
your presence and your polite your
politeness and so forth is you're
rewarding a positive direction but we
don't I wouldn't tolerate any person on
the planet treating my wife that way
okay okay no that definitely clear that
definitely helps say about you
appreciate it sure can die I got to tell
you it's really hard what you're going
through I'm sorry you're facing yes I
appreciate all your wisdom and I am
looking forward to my first waffle house
Thanksgiving this so it doesn't have to
be waffles I was a metaphor
pick up the book boundaries by dr. Henry
cloud and it will help you clarify some
of the stuff that that we you and I were
just discussing it'll give you some some
verbage around it and some constructs
around it
Henry is a wonderful Christian guy and
is a brilliant brilliant psychologist
psychiatrist and so really this book is
it's a life's work of his and it's you
got to read it it's perfect for this
situation and it'll give you good
guidelines but yeah you can't allow
someone that's being that way around
your family that's awful though it's sad
that young man's acting that way but
we're not gonna we're not gonna tolerate
that stuff so open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
know let's extend that little bell we've
got a large number of you listening that
have a young male under 30 that's living
in your basement and is in some cases is
behaving in a way that you wouldn't
tolerate off of anyone else
so you're enabling not only their lack
of productivity and their lack of
emotional growth to become a standalone
adult in the real world but you're also
enabling their misbehavior and so the
rule of thumb is if you're gonna have a
grown person in your house they need to
abide by your rules and your values in
other words if you're gonna live under
my roof you're not gonna do drugs you're
gonna live under my roof you're not
gonna come home drunk every night you're
gonna live under my roof you're gonna
get a job or six of them and keep it if
you're gonna live under my roof you're
gonna be in church on Sunday morning if
you don't want to do that it's okay but
the people that live under my roof
that's what they do if you're not under
my roof it's okay you can decide
whatever you want to them some of you
don't like that that's fine you don't
have to live under my roof it's okay but
I'm the king of that dadgum castle and I
make the rules there and even the dogs
go along with that they're gonna behave
in a way that is good for them and good
for our household even the pets behave
and that's not mean it's not nasty and
it's not a disciplinarian it's not any
of those things it's a simple thing of
we've got a set of values that we've
ascribed to our family that cause us to
win long term what are you going to be
when you're thirty if you're 26 right
now if you're 23 right now you're living
in your mother's basement what are you
gonna be when you're 30 and what's the
best set of circumstances to get you
there
to manhood to womanhood you gonna think
about this you know any Eagle the stays
in the nest too long is known as a
turkey